y el gra fue fugaz el tercer gabinete
nombrado por pedro castillo tras haberlo
juramentado el 2 de febrero el jefe de
estado anunció que una vez mas
recompondrá su consejo de ministros otra
acción orientada a intentar remediar la
crisis política en la que está sumida el
ejecutivo he tomado la decisión de
recomponer el gabinete ministerial
y estos cambios se harán teniendo en
cuenta la apertura
a las fuerzas políticas académicas y
profesionales del país esta se suma a
otras por las que ya ha atravesado
castillo desde su llegada al poder el 28
de julio tiene su origen en el
nombramiento de héctor para leer como
primer ministro
una figura criticada por la oposición y
por movimientos feministas que se
manifestaron en las calles de lima este
viernes señalan a valer de presuntamente
haber incurrido en actos de violencia
doméstica contra su hija y su ya difunto
esposa el congreso peruano liderado por
la oposición rechazó el 4 de febrero el
pedido de valer para solicitar su voto
de confianza al tiempo que según la
prensa peruana crecieron los
cuestionamientos en contra del ministro
el ministro del ambiente y la ministra
de la mujer y poblaciones vulnerables
y
a otras personas que también
[Música]
castillo prometió que el consejo de
ministros incluirá voces de diversos
sectores políticos un nuevo gabinete que
sería el cuarto nombrado en los pocos
más de seis meses en el cargo castillo
espera poder destrabar el juego político
y obtener la tan ansiada gobernabilidad
el mandatario invitó al congreso a dejar
de lado las confrontaciones y el
obstruccionismo y concentrarse en las
necesidades urgentes de la población